on va continuer alors effectivement sur
la salle des fêtes son intervention ça a
eu un effet puisque la réception bien
meilleur qu'il ya quinze jours mais pas
au point d'avoir fait basculer la
majorité puis qui reste quand même
majoritairement pas convaincre sur sur
les mesures on est à des coûts très
importants entre 60 et 70 % annoncés
c'est le sens des choses aux gens c'est
rare qu'ils disent qu'ils n'en veulent
pas et 54 % qui pensent qu'il a pris la
mesure de la situation
je pense que c'est un chiffre cependant
parce qu'on lui reprochait c'était
précisément d'être autiste est sans
doute encore aussi important il ya une
question qui était à bâtir montré qu'ils
comprenaient la préoccupation des
français 49% 18 50 % non mais c'est vrai
qu'elle a 43 ans qui disent oui il ya ya
quinze jours c'était bon sens à tout
casser entr'autre ex non mais si c'est
ça permettra plus gêné les dons qu'elle
était nécessaire cette attention est ce
que s'alarmer de renault est vraiment je
pense qu'on n'en est pas encore là mais
ça c'était utile bloc les faits scission
possible au sein du gilet jaune carole
moi je j'ai tendance à penser que
il y avait de ça dans ce qu'on a entendu
hier de mâcon parce que bon d'abord
quand même ces mesures c'est très retour
à l'ancien monde c'est l'augmentation du
smic
oui ou brest et donc les smicards les
retraités
évidemment parce que ça
ça avait choqué un peu tout le monde et
puis d'autre part ce sont quand même des
gens qui votent on sait et les retraités
ont beaucoup à apprendre à cran donc il
y avait vraiment les retraités les
smicards après il manque peut-être on
verra il y aura peut-être d'autres
choses mais pour le moment de ce que
j'ai entendu hier soir il n'y a rien
pour la petite classe moyenne qui est
juste au dessus même les heures sup de
version même un faux pas et puis et puis
à mesure je sakho j'attends bien aimé la
suppression des factions oublier sa
caricature il y avait aussi des petits
commerçants des artisans etc
donc moi je me demande même une
opération oui division en 2d gilet jaune
espérer c'est effectivement une des uns
des objectifs
oui je crois que ce qui est intéressant
est ce qui était fondamental c'est de
garder en fait là le potentiel de
transformation et on a vu d'ailleurs un
premier ministre est déterminé tout à
l'heure et nous sommes déterminés à
continuer dans ce qui était important
c'est à la fois de faire des gestes très
conséquent et en même temps de ne pas
renoncer de ne pas de ne rien faire qui
qui qui nous qui nous empêche de faire
ça et je crois que parmi les les mesures
qui ont été annoncées tout pratiquement
était prévu y compris la défiscalisation
puisqu'elle n'aurait vu le vide plutôt
arnaud a dit le premier ministre est
plus fort mais qui est très important
c'est à dire que des quand vous êtes
dans une accélération on est à l'écouté
on prend des risques on prend la mesure
de l'urgence et
et ça a été fait mais la défiscalisation
des heures sup et des heures
supplémentaires était prévue un peu plus
tard mais en attendant c'est dans les
programmes dans la dans la programmation
de baisse de fiscales à hauteur de 3
milliards ensuite vous avez également
pour le smic c'était prévu mais sur cinq
ans on le fait sur un an
donc c'est l'accélération est donc pour
moi on n'est pas du tout dans
l'incohérence et on reste avec ce cap
mais je ne reviendrai si vous le voulez
bien tout à l'heure sur le cas pas les
causes avoir quelqu'un alexis ces
retours à cette affaire de
transformation c'est le discours de me
dire on recule pas on accélère c'est
évidemment un extraordinaire recul c'est
évidemment un désastre et vous avez
raison de vous interroger sur la
capacité transformatrices pour la suite
c'est la clé de la faire il est à
craindre et je dis vraiment être à
craindre de façon honnête il est à
craindre que cette affaire est ruiné
pour longtemps il s'en est peut-être
définitivement la capacité de maquereau
en faire quoi que ce soit à réformer
quoi que ce soit ensuite mais il ya ça
on peut en discuter nous n'en savons
rien et je sais c'est une crainte mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que les mesures qui
ont été annoncées hier ne sont en rien
des mesures comme on dit mme dans ce
jargon effrayant qui d'ailleurs
exaspèrent les gens transformatrices
parce que j'aime pas du tout envie qu'on
transforme le repli mais c'est une autre
affaire elles sont en rien des
transformatrices augmenter le smic c'est
pas transformateurs ces sympathiques
annulé la hausse de la csg
ça nous transforme rien c'est juste
qu'on on a tapé sa tête des gens leur
rock ou dessous c'est pas une
transformation c'est c'est le cd
l'augmentation cd sogo sur un an
ces mesures nous devons avancer des
solutions des seaux d'eau sur un
incendie des seaux d'eau
extraordinairement coûteux et des seaux
d'eau qui sont d'abord nécessaire il
faut pas nous raconter que c'est des
réformes
c'est vraiment jette de l'eau on jette
de l'eau pourrait essayer d'éteindre et
j'espère comme vous que ça va éteindre
mais c'est pas de la réforme
alors justement sur le côté qui va payer
je voudrais qu'on écoute parce que c'est
le coeur du sujet aussi parce que le
coût de tout ça c'est entre 10
il y a on va reparler d'animer je donne
les grandes lignes 10 milliards pour ces
mesures quatre milliards et demi pour la
suppression de la hausse de la taxe sur
les carburants
ça fait quand même une facture assez
élevé ça va être difficile de rester
dans les clous du déficit à 3% du pib
alors est-ce au contribuable de payer s
à l'état de faire des économies benjamin
griveaux porte parole du gouvernement
promet des économies pour l'écouter eh
bien nous allons faire des économies
comme nous nous y sommes engagés
vous le savez d'abord des économies dans
le mode de fonctionnement de l'état et
sa 7 mai nous de le mettre en oeuvre
mais regardez vous allez avoir au 1er
janvier quelque chose qu'elle s'appelait
le prélèvement à la source on en a
beaucoup parlé à votre antenne wi qui
veut dire concrètement que les
fonctionnaires à bercy qui s'occupait de
l'impôt sur le revenu par définition
quand on va le prélevé à la source
ils vont avoir moins d'activité ou alors
c'est qu'il ya un problème eh bien nous
allons réduire la voilure de certains
services de l'état cpt enisa air de dire
que la facture elle est pas si forte que
ça ou ça fait pas lourd et des classes
ce fut une crise sociale au départ
coagulé un certain nombre de
mécontentement maintenant une crise
politique je pense que si mme après on
peut le protéger par des institutions
conçu par deux vols pour que l'exécutif
tiennent debout macro on peut aller
jusqu'au bout de son septennat comme ça
ils ne sont en rien quinquennat ce qui
malheureusement ne sont inquiètes mais
malheureusement mais s'il veut encore
s'il encore des velléités de transformer
la france d'en faire quelque chose de
beau d'un peu grande ça je crois que les
faux part d'audience et une crise
politique et une crise politique est une
réponse politique dans les institutions
il a des outils référendum la changer de
majorité il peut le faire mais si on
s'en tient effectivement
d'autres se disent ou scooter la
dissolution savez ça provoquerait
effectivement je crains qu'ils auraient
beaucoup de députés en marche qui ne
seraient pas réelles voilà il vous
verneret il ferait bien la chancelière
merkel à gouverner et c'est l'allemagne
est fort bien avec un gouvernement
composite et puis ça a préparé peut-être
sa réélection plus sur mon manque de
sucre année c'est la barre qui n'a pas
ses papiers d un modèle pour la joie il
n a plus de légitimité dans les
profondeurs donc oui il pourra pas faire
grand chose et c'est dommage pour la
france hier le plus de légitimité
oui donc moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que vous avez noté par exemple
qu'il n'est pas revenu sur la refonte de
l'usf je voulais revenir là dessus que
ça me semble très important parce que
quel est l'enjeu
quel est l'enjeu et qu'elle est en
réalité le véritable cap d'emmanuel
macron et je crois que ça vous pouvez le
partager
c'est que c'est d'arrêter de monter les
français les uns contre les autres de
penser qu' il faut appauvrir les riches
plutôt que d'enrichir les pauvres c'est
à dire que et ça c'est très important
d'avoir tenu sur l' isf parce qu'il
s'agit de dire quand on veut relancer
l'économie ont fait pas des cadeaux aux
copains et ses profonds et je vous le
dis parce que moi c'est le sens de mon
engagement et je suis convaincu que
c'est aussi le cas pour c'est à dire il
faut relancer l'économie pour relancer
l'économie
il a fallu revenir sur les sf est
effectivement avoir une taxation qui est
équivalent le sens de l'encouragement de
tout ce qui est investissement productif
parce que c'est absolument essentiel
pour notre pays d'ailleurs ça commence à
repartir
donc il faut et c'est ça l'enjeu et je
pense pas que ce soit perdu il faut
comprendre que relancer l'économie c'est
la condition pour pouvoir relancer aussi
d'abord lutter contre le chômage de mars
dont souffrent de manière prioritaire
qui les les gens dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure et qui dit et nous ne pensons
qu'à eux
parce qu'en réalité comme l'a dit
emmanuel macron les riches ils ont même
pas besoin de président qui s'en sortent
toujours il faut croire à la sincérité
ce propos dont je crois que c'est ça le
véritable enjeu est le véritable cap
c'est de comprendre que ce qui est
poursuivi
c'est une justice sociale mais qui
s'assoit sur une relance économique
qu'il faut arrêter de monter les riches
contre les pauvres les deux de sa réussi
à faire ça on aura vraiment réussi c'est
de la condition du nord et monica sur le
fait de ne ne pas renoncer à la
suppression de l'sf moi je parie qu'ils
soient pas également sous pression de
l'usf
je pense qu'il ne l'a pas fait parce que
le faire s'arrêter ça aurait été rajouté
une humiliation symbolique à une
humiliation symbolique et que là c'était
plus qu'il ne pouvait supporter et donc
tant mieux qu'il l'ait pas fait mais il
faut bien voir l'ampleur du revirement
qui est en train de se jouer parce que
ces mesures qui vont coûter 12 14 15
milliards comment on va les financer
lors du déficit et donc on va plus
respectés des clous de maastricht d'une
part et d'autre part par une taxation
sur les entreprises
donc on va pouvoir voir le ciel soit
revoir l'impôt sur les sociétés qui sont
plutôt prête à jouer le jeu si on en
croit qu'ils sont le terreau à la part
du revêtement pas récurrents pas le
choix il faudra bien financer katende et
on a parlé d'un de la lutte contre
contre l'évasion fiscale s'est très vite
on négocier aussi avec bruxelles avait
d'ailleurs et bien voilà donc un peu de
déficit il ya un litrage il ya eu un
arbitrage qui a été fait il ne se fera
pas au détriment des entreprises parce
que là on serait dans l'incohérence
ben je sais nous sommes à nous verrons
bien je pense qu'il y aura un peu de
déficit et richard ferrand l'a déjà dit
et un peu mais pas de taxe sur les
entreprises mais de retard dans la dent
des mesures condé prendre en faveur des
entrevues c'est à dire la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés on va faire
moitié-moitié mixer mais à les mixer la
tuyauterie ça il faut bien voir que tous
leurs versements philosophie qui est
derrière tout ça c'est que emmanuel
macron est arrivé comme un neuro p1
portant le projet européen l'orthodoxie
budgétaire pour permettre de notre de
convaincre à l'échelle européenne pour
faire des réformes européennes
d'une part en s'appuyant sur les
entreprises d'autre part il va en être
réduit pour solder cette crise a
abandonné cet idéal européen qu'il avait
en tout cas de respect de l'orthodoxie
budgétaire pour convaincre les autres
partenaires et
mais l'europe première points et
deuxième point je crains aussi qu'il
soit entre qu'ils soient obligés en tout
cas d'ajourner ces mesures qui voulait
faire pour les entreprises et à
l'arrivée ce sera mauvais pour l'emploi
et la croissance
mais donc c'est pas du tout derrière à
mesure qu'elle serait bien c'est énorme
et vous savez que dans ces 3 % on est à
1,9 si on fait exception si on fait ben
oui il ya des taxes exceptionnelles qui
ne se reproduiront pas donc bruxelles
c'est entendre cela est ce que vous
pensez que l'arbitrage a été mauvais est
ce que vous pensez qu'il ne fallait pas
répondre par des gestes les jeux dit
qu'il fallait jouer je dis ça je suis
dit qu'il fallait le faire je dis qu'il
ne faut pas en minorer les conséquences
financières ni j'ai largement la portée
politique
carole ammoun à plus de ce que j'en ai à
l'excès claire 2004 il observera la
réaction très négative de bruxelles
d'une part vers l'un de l'autre depuis
hier à l'intervention du président macro
ils ont peur ils nous a il a voulu nous
nous sommes embarqués dans une voie et
finalement on aurait pu se laisser
séduire
et puis il est en train d'en revenir
considère comme des fondamentaux
fâcheuse de nos de ses prédécesseurs
s'étaient pas écrit d'avancé
ce différend ce n'était pas écrit
d'avancé le problème c'est que il a
quand même fait beaucoup de choses à
l'envers
il commence par exemple par la réforme
du travail alors qu'il aurait peut-être
fallu pour donner un signal à l'opinion
commencer par la réforme de la formation
professionnelle pour montrer qu'on
s'était après celle en dhr est très
important et symboliquement je pense que
c'était très simple à 15 millions de
bornes de rodez 6 6 2 ensuite le
problème
effectivement je pense que puisque liée
s'est fait un symbole pour la gauche il
est évidemment aussi pour les
investisseurs et les entreprises que
probablement de la faillite kg pour cent
des français sont contre la suppression
je sais je sais pas ce que les banques
assurances et le supprime
quand il supprime ils sont 55 est pas
content parce que mais c'est pas
catastrophique mandat populaire ça a été
quand même le péché originel vieux
malades ou en fin d'action médicale ce
qui a été le cas ces cons c'est d'avoir
comment dire différer la baisse de la
taxe d'habitation et de l'avoir sont si
serrés au début tu sais
voilà c'est 70 chats à fouetter my own
rien compréhensible entre taxe
d'habitation et que je te l'enlève et
que la csg je te la montée que ceux ci
s'est totalement technocratique les
impôts soit on n'y touche pas ce sont
les baisses mais on fait pas des
transferts quand on fait des transferts
les gens qui en bénéficient ne sont pas
qu'on ne se rendent pas compte et les
gens qui en pratique sont furieux les
laisser vraiment le truc de techno il ya
une espèce de mécanique incroyable de
tuyaux fiscaux qui aboutit à ça mais je
crois qu'à une prise de conscience et
que pourrait que pour le coup on ouvre
une nouvelle époque
et hier il y avait des choses claires
qui ont été expliqués et qui ont été
comprises et si on a vous savez on a
souvent parlé de pédagogie ces derniers
mois vous avez raison il y avait des
choses qui étaient un peu trop complexe
même si elle pouvait être futé et donc
je crois que ça a été compris au plus
haut niveau et contourne peut-être une
page et vous en réjouissez 6 septembre
les commentaires de nice est précieux
alors j ai la finul
ilana on laisse quelques commentaires de
nos internautes jlr les gilets jaunes
doivent continuer à accepter ça serait
prouvé que nous sommes des imbéciles r34
la réforme des retraites est nécessaire
et sera douloureuse nous vivons au
dessus de nos moyens sur cette relation
à bercy le d'impôt à la source wiki kéké
qui va être évidemment le nouveau
problème du de la rentrée ça va être
très compliqué les gens veulent furieux
etc
il a failli le supprimer il s'est à son
tour mais il trompe ou jusqu'au moment
ils vont en parler et je comment ils
vont sans en subir les conséquences
il a il s'était mis en situation et il a
cédé à bercy que yann on peut le faire
on s'est engagés on a fait tourner dans
un ordinateur on a mis tous nos gars là
dedans il faut y aller l'europe les sens
il avait failli la faille reculer dix
jours plus tôt et je pense que c'est à
dire que reculer dix jours plus tôt sera
écouté au moins deux ou trois fois moins
cher et pareil on lui a dit non non on
peut plus maintenant c'est fait c'est
fait on va trouver les 4 milliards
résultat ça rend coût de 15 là il ya un
problème aussi entre le président et son
premier ministre et c'est la
technostructure bercy qui n'est pas le
cas matignon qui est au ciel
moi je crois qu'il est prise de
conscience du couple de l'exécutif qui
tire partie avec avec pas mal d'énergie
et d'eau et on va voir ce que ça va
donner mais je crois qu'il ya une prise
de conscience en tout cas de la
complexité trop grande d'un certain
nombre de ces pas qu'elle était mal
expliqué c'est qu'elle était difficile à
expliquer et ça ça va pas donc ça je
crois que je crois qu'on l'a compris des
gens va déjà 20 au delà de considérants
économique il aurait cherché qu'il ya un
sentiment de désarroi de dépossession de
précarité dans le peuple qui va bien au
delà de ces seuils est-ce que ça il en
racontant il ya quelques phrases qui
donne à penser dans son intervention où
c'est le garder mais ça par définition
si on prend par exemple le cas des
services publics de prendre la mairie de
l'acsel ont disparu les choses comme ça
je ne sais d'ailleurs absolument pas
s'il est question d'en remettre ça ça
coûte cher on les a pas supprimée pour
rien
mais ça de par définition même si
c'était dans projet c'est du très long
terme mais à long terme de quatre
monnaies mais je vais terminer la phrase
de donner parce que je sais ils entrent
évidemment la question de la sécurité
culturelle de l'identité et donc de oui
ça c'est important des meubles et donc
il nous dit qu'il va faire un grand
débat sur l'identité ça nous rappelle
les souvenirs évident pourquoi passion
mais mais très bien mais tronquée mais
au même moment il va signer le traité de
marrakech
enfin le pacte de marrakech n'est pas
adroit ce qui était d'une maladresse
insigne
il épaule contractée par mais à quoi bon
le faire à la cachette une chose on peut
en parler j'avais bu nation n'est
évidemment pas anodin c'est évident que
c'est dans ce malade yassa d'abord c'est
juste qu'on suive un petit peu le fil
d'un de penser je voudrais qu'on aborde
aussi l'angle finalement
faut-il tout casser pour se faire
entendre